[Music]
you like this movie so much for so many
reasons rays are so great in it and it
just feels like a movie that we need
right now it's a fun movie it's an
escape movie it is all these great
family messages that there's an imminent
storyline to it it's just so wonderful
all in all could you guys be any happier
if I was nobody better yeah maybe a
little bit you were an essay about I
feel extremely blessed and then we just
came off keneniah and Nico Santos who
plays Oliver he just came off a regional
press tour and to see the response you
know in around the country was amazing
you know people people want this movie
they want to see it and they love it and
it makes them it inspires and it makes
them feel a certain way and there's no
better feeling I think John shoe called
you guys and I quote the Avengers of a
thing Asian movies okay you like
superheroes like who's Thor who's Black
Widow in this crew you know more you you
know you think you're you but you are
mad like the Weezer or the Steel
Magnolias you know what I mean okay
that's I don't I don't
yeah yeah you know what I feel like baby
Groot I feel like baby Groot
oh and what it did cause I don't know
yeah
what is he gonna do for me you know what
I mean if I'm trapped in a garbage
disposal what is he gonna do I think
just the the fact that he is I don't
want to hear about Gugu
that's right yeah but group would not be
do you know do you think that's why she
makes big bucks because she knows how to
whip out garbage is under lexicon you
brought it to another you brought it to
a darker playing that's gonna happen of
course everybody's thinking about
watching this movie and thinking about
that moment when you do bring somebody
home to meet your family yes so is it
just universally scary or in Asian
families is it really harder to bring
somebody home to the family it's
universally scary and I mean come on
yeah there's always that feeling of like
am i enough right and that and that week
you know question is even asked in the
movie I think with this specifically it
ties into Asian culture but it also
turns into like you know the history of
the young family which is a pretty hard
family to go home to but I think in that
way there's a journey that rachel goes
through that I think you know every
woman or man also goes through with when
they're in love and I think that in that
way this movie is an extremely universal
aside from like its cultural
significance it's very very relatable
and enjoyable if you guys had your own
experiences bringing somebody home to
meet the family like who and your own
family is the hardest nut to crack if
you bring home significant others
nothing what this movie represents for
me like you know growing up
korean-american like my parents are
first-generation immigrants Korean so if
I was bringing someone home who let's
say wasn't Korean or not Korean enough
those themes you know I related to I
really to all too well you know and so
but this to do in this backdrop that's
even more amplified but yet tethered in
realities my family just wants me to
find someone
Oh Oh him he'll do anybody needs to move
out smells like scalp check out you know
the Patino's don't you live with your
family stuff you know gonna wanna move
it I'm moving out I'm tired of slices
are a Roth IRA and I'm gonna withdraw
from it yeah I'm tired of sleeping near
this garbage to sleep in had to tell
like the Willy Wonka family how proud of
you is your family if we're people were
really talking I'm gonna be honest
there's nothing there they couldn't be
prouder they're cool with it they're
cool with it like my grandma like she
goes on YouTube and she like YouTube's
Aquafina but she understand there's an
algorithm so the more you YouTube
something specific the more all of that
will come up so she's like it's like I
just want to watch normal stuff but it's
all Aquafina my YouTube like why are you
taking over YouTube cooking no idea with
you guys recommended for you understand
the algorithm yeah yeah they probably
won't because it's recommended I feel
the first time seeing you in that blonde
wig they laugh yeah laughs mockingly and
then told me that usually why don't you
just act like well I'm actually met her
in a good way right right I understand
for me like as a Native American I
really wanted my grandma to see this
movie because I think that I think that
you'd be proud so much to be proud of
the wig I gotta ask you a few more about
that cuz it was just so fun to see you
you looked like you were just having so
much fun it was I to see how long my
hair is did you not like the way I loved
the wig I mean it was so piggelin he was
just you know kind of suffering under it
that was like I didn't know the junket
is so wig Bay's dang I should have worn
those cornrows like I initially [ __ ] -
J - it's hard to wear away but worth it
but worth it it's like a you give me a
little Miley side
five with it yeah there was a little bit
of that yeah Feeny min this is that okay
and I'm guessing people must come up to
you all the time for the hangover movie
oh yeah and come up to you for this
movie are you like excited for that to
happen
look I I'm just look I'm excited to get
up out of bed and just drink a cup of
coffee you know that I like and that's
not lactose intolerant milked and I just
get to use coffee made the way my kids
just like so yes yes but people they
come up like hangover movies coming at
you the quotes all the - oh yeah I've
read first regen every is one of those
look I have a very different story we
used to be a physician and you know is
it just a dream to be an actor so just
to work just to work at this level and
to work with amazing actors like Maura
is just it's just been Heaven Sent I'm
just living my best life right now when
I heard that you even kind of teared up
watching the dailies I did a moment for
you oceans aid in this movie how is that
all feeling and what is making you so
much love it you know a lot of my career
spent in production you know what I mean
like I haven't really I never saw myself
act and then you know went for this
movie specifically mood that night that
I cried it was um it was the feeling
that this movie was bigger than myself
and that I was a part of it it was yeah
I was a very powerful moment for me yeah
bring me to tears all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]